Jennifer Lawrence has all but vanished from
the public eye in recent months, with the
global pandemic responsible for a slew of
movie shutdowns.
Even though she appears to be taking a backseat
right now, Lawrence has been working pretty
much non-stop since she was a teenager.
It always seems like an urban legend when
you hear that a famous actor was scouted on
the street, but according to Jennifer Lawrence,
that really happened.
She was just 14 years old and visiting New
York City when she was spotted by a modeling
agent.
Lawrence told Vanity Fair in 2013,
"I was playing field hockey and cheerleading
and wanted to be a doctor — but within 20
minutes, in the cab ride from the hotel room,
I decided I didn't want to be a model, that,
in fact, I wanted to be an actress, and I
would only sign with an agency if they would
let me audition for commercials and act as
well."
Lawrence's impulsive decision paid off, as
she revealed to Vanity Fair,
"And one of them gave me a script, to audition
the next day, and I read the script and it
was the first time I had that feeling like
I understand this.
This is the first time I've ever understood
anything.
[...] I always felt like I sucked at everything,
that I could never find the thing that I liked.
I auditioned and I probably sucked, but I
had decided 100 percent that this is what
I wanted to do."
Despite her knee-jerk reaction to the opportunity,
14 is pretty young to make such a big decision,
and her career moved faster than anyone could
have anticipated.
Making the huge decision to pursue acting
full-time at such a young age would be daunting
to begin with, but in Lawrence's case, she
gave up something even bigger, when she dropped
out of middle school, and never earned a high
school diploma.
In conversation with Bill Whitaker of CBS
News, Lawrence explained that she never felt
comfortable in school, and revealed that she
had to convince her parents to let her drop
out and make the leap to full-time acting.
Lawrence explained,
"It's so hard to explain it was just an overwhelming
feeling of, 'I get this.
This is what I was meant to do.'
And to get people to try to understand that
when you're 14 years old.
Wanting to drop out of school and do this
and your parents are just, like, 'You're out
of your mind.'"
"I dropped out of middle school.
I don't technically have a GED or a diploma."
Though she said she doesn't regret her choice,
the weight of this decision must have been
enormous for a young teenager.
Before long, Lawrence's career would skyrocket,
which would put academic pursuits on the back
burner for the foreseeable future.
In 2010, Jennifer Lawrence's biggest break
came in the form of Winter's Bone, an Ozarks-set
drama that cast Lawrence as a hard-scrabbling
teen trying to protect her family from poverty,
a harsh winter, and homelessness in the mountain
range.
As the de facto head of her family, Lawrence
came off as wise beyond her years, and to
film the role, she endured some pretty harrowing
experiences, including skinning a dead squirrel.
However, her work paid off.
In the aftermath of the independent film's
release, Lawrence earned widespread acclaim
and an Academy Award nomination for her work
in the role.
Now one of the hottest rising stars in the
film industry, Lawrence was more visible than
ever, catapulted into stardom at an insanely
quick pace as well as at a staggeringly young
age.
After one leading film role, Jennifer Lawrence
became one of the most recognizable faces
in Hollywood, and when she debuted a bombshell
look at the 2011 Academy Awards to celebrate
her nomination for Winter's Bone, it only
contributed to her fast-growing popularity.
Before long, Lawrence was fielding a ton of
movie offers, and just a few years after her
first nomination, she made history with her
first win.
Two years after Winter's Bone, Lawrence starred
alongside Bradley Cooper under the direction
of David O. Russell in the 2012 film Silver
Linings Playbook, and her performance as Tiffany,
a widow looking for love in all the wrong
places, earned her the most critical accolades
of her career to date.
After winning a string of other awards, including
a Golden Globe, Lawrence took home the Academy
Award for Best Actress in early 2013, making
her the second youngest winner in the category.
Just one year later, she set a record as the
youngest ever three-time nominee thanks to
her performance in Russell's American Hustle.
Even before she won her Oscar for Silver Linings
Playbook, Lawrence had cemented her status
in Hollywood thanks to major roles in some
of the industry's biggest franchises.
In 2011, Lawrence joined the cast of X-Men:
First Class, where she played Mystique, a
role that she would later reprise in 2014's
Days of Future Past, 2016's Apocalypse and
2019’s Dark Phoenix.
However, you may actually know her best from
her starring role as heroine Katniss Everdeen
in the Hunger Games franchise, which spawned
four films and made Lawrence the highest-grossing
action heroine of all time.
Lawrence also partnered with David O. Russell
and Bradley Cooper for several different projects,
including Silver Linings Playbook, American
Hustle, and 2015's Joy.
Lawrence was an undeniable star around the
world by the time she was just 22 years old,
and it's hard not to think that such a speedy
ascent to fame might have been an awful lot
to handle at such a young age.
Beyond her onscreen performances, Lawrence
quickly became one of the most recognizable
figures in Hollywood thanks to her public
persona, which drew a wide variety of reactions
from the general public as she settled into
stardom.
Right off the bat, Lawrence presented herself
as a "cool girl" who would drink to excess,
make raunchy jokes, and do away with any pretension.
"And then, I don't know.
Something in me just snapped.
Couldn't have been the alcohol."
For many women, this was a refreshing change
of pace for such a huge celebrity, but as
with all things, the internet backlash followed
swiftly and intensely.
Whether Lawrence was putting on an act or
simply being herself, the damage was done,
and the backlash hit hard, with the star being
accused of faking a relatable public persona
just to score likability points.
Whether or not her critics had any idea what
they were talking about, that can't have been
an easy thing for Lawrence to endure, and
unfortunately for her, the wave of backlash
preceded some of her least popular film releases.
Flush with industry capital after several
huge early successes, Jennifer Lawrence signed
on to appear in several films that, unfortunately,
didn't bring her much acclaim or success.
She reunited with David O. Russell for the
biopic Joy, which cast Lawrence as the creator
of the Miracle Mop.
Sadly, the movie wasn't received as well as
their previous collaborations.
To make matters worse, 2016's X-Men: Apocalypse
also received mediocre reviews, despite a
respectable performance at the box office.
Lawrence's final project of 2016, Passengers,
had every ingredient for success on paper,
between its high-concept space setting and
Lawrence's co-star Chris Pratt.
Though Pratt and Lawrence both earned praise
for their performances, the film was largely
disliked, thanks in large part to an unsettling
third act twist, making for a third consecutive
critical flop for Lawrence.
Following her appearances in several high-profile
critical failures throughout 2016, Lawrence
returned to her roots in smaller independent
films in 2017.
Unfortunately, this decision didn't quite
pan out either.
Lawrence took a huge career leap by taking
on the title role in Darren Aronofsky's mother!,
a disturbing horror film that should have
put her firmly back on the map as an actor
to watch.
When all was said and done, mother! wasn't
the career resurgence Lawrence needed at all,
and as her only film project in 2017, it left
a lasting impression of a career that seemed
to be on the decline.
In the aftermath of mother!'s release, Jennifer
Lawrence returned to big-budget projects,
which also didn't work out as she likely planned.
In 2018, Lawrence headlined the spy drama
Red Sparrow, which cast her as a prima ballerina
who becomes a spy when she's tasked to work
for the original incarnation of the KGB, which
was known in Russia as the SVR.
Despite intense training for the role, Red
Sparrow, which reunited Lawrence with her
Hunger Games director Francis Lawrence — no
relation — performed acceptably at the box
office, but was largely a critical failure.
Lawrence's next project, the X-Men movie Dark
Phoenix, which saw her reprising her role
as the mutant Mystique alongside an ensemble
cast that included Game of Thrones star Sophie
Turner, suffered an even worse fate.
Panned by critics and rejected by audiences,
the film became the lowest-grossing entry
in the X-Men franchise, though it was later
unseated by 2020's New Mutants, which was
released during a global pandemic.
Sadly for Lawrence, her most recent film projects
definitely didn't go as planned, and left
her with a string of flops in their wake.
"That just gets me going."
Ultimately, Jennifer Lawrence's break from
public life has more to do with the pandemic
than any major career decisions.
The actress has multiple projects in development,
many of which have been delayed, but will
likely hit our screens in the coming months.
And any recent career setbacks aside, her
personal life has also taken center stage,
in good ways as well as bad ones.
Lawrence was the subject of a cruel data leak
in 2014, and her friendships with Amy Schumer
and the Kardashian family have been the subject
of tabloid attention, sometimes overshadowing
her impressive artistic accomplishments.
In October of 2019, Lawrence wed art gallery
director Cooke Maroney and has been largely
off the radar since.
However, as E! Online reported in 2018, Lawrence
also just thinks it's healthy to take a break
from Hollywood once in a while, and she took
a scheduled hiatus that year..
And thanks to this performer's sheer talent,
it's safe to assume she'll return to the big
screen whenever she wants to.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.